hey everybody uh my name is carter
rabasa and before i dive into my talk i
have a quick question for everyone here
in the audience can you please raise
your hand if you've ever organized a
meetup a hack day a node copter a
conference anything that brought
developers together
all right cool so maybe uh maybe
one-third to one-fourth of the people
here fantastic so the title of my talk
is a community a community of people not
projects and i have two very modest
goals for this talk
for those of you who didn't raise your
hand i'm hoping that this talk
encourages some of you to get a little
bit more involved in the developer
community where you live
or at the very least just talk to people
who are and find out why they do what
they do
for those of you who did raise your hand
i'd like to share a few things that i've
learned about making community
involvement a more
sustainable proposition
especially for those of you who have
families and full-time jobs because it
can be really difficult to balance these
things
but first a little bit a little bit
about me to provide some context for why
i'm giving this talk
so my name is carter and i'm a developer
evangelist for a company called twilio
twilio provides a service for developers
that makes it really easy to
programmatically send and receive text
messages and make and receive voice and
voice over iphone calls i joined twilio
about two and a half years ago this is
actually a photo of me shortly after i
joined the company
people tell me that i've grown up a lot
since then
all right so this is not me um this is
actually a photo of my daughter
catherine interestingly enough it was
actually taken at a jsconf us in 2012. i
was really lucky i was able to bring
catherine down to this conference and
kind of show her around and show her a
little bit of what her father does for a
living um i've been married for just
over five years my wife carrie and i
have two daughters so you met catherine
and that's that's a little emily right
there on the bottom left and the four of
us live in seattle washington so we're
not from seattle
i'm from washington dc carries from
upstate new york but we moved out to
seattle because i got a job at microsoft
and i worked at microsoft for a few
years the last two of which i actually
worked on the internet explorer team and
seattle is the home or it was the
location of the first ever cascadia js
so cascade ajs is a conference that i
founded in 2012 and it's a javascript
conference for uh for developers in the
pacific northwest
now you might be asking yourself how i
got into organizing a conference and in
my case the answer is relatively
straightforward
so when i joined twilio in january of
2012 i had never been a developer
evangelist before i really only had a
rough idea of what the job entailed and
shortly after i joined the company it
was explained to me that a big component
of my job was going to be supporting my
local developer community
and frankly that seemed like a really
open-ended thing which meant that it was
absolutely terrifying but also really
really exciting so i had to figure out
for me
what it meant to support the seattle
developer community and i've been a
javascript developer since the late 90s
so for me i decided to spend a lot more
time in seattle js so seattle.js is
seattle's largest javascript meetup it's
been around for a long time and i just
started going i started talking to
people there getting to know the
community i started helping out with
organization
and during i'd say like january to june
i kept having the same conversation with
people people were really frustrated
that every time they wanted to go to a
good javascript conference they had to
get on a plane and they had to fly to
scottsdale or amelia island or berlin or
lisbon
it just seemed really weird
that there was nothing like that in the
seattle area
and i and i totally agreed and i talked
to some some
community organizers down in portland
and up in vancouver bc and there was
this sentiment that there that we really
wanted something for us so that's where
cascadia.js came from um it was uh
heavily inspired by jsconf jsconfiu lxjs
node conf all of the conferences that
you think of as being the best of what a
developer conference can be
and we put on this event in november of
2012 and it was just uh it was a huge
success
you know we pulled together just over
200 amazing people for two days of fun
and uh it was just one of the most
rewarding experiences i'd ever had
and the feed the feedback was very very
positive
and people liked lots of different
things you know they like the coffee and
they like the food
but the recurring theme over and over
again was that people were so delighted
to meet other people
and not just within the city that they
lived in but people in seattle were so
happy to meet other
interesting and amazing people down in
portland or up in vancouver and i felt
that we had really succeeded in
connecting developers up and down the
pacific northwest
so i i left so the conference ended and
i was on this real high cloud
and i don't know about you um but uh you
know i uh i had a fever right
i had a fever and the only prescription
was gonna be more events right more
conferences more more opportunities to
create experiences um for my fellow
developers um and that's all i could
think about and i started to think ahead
to 2013 and sure enough 2013 was a
really really busy year for me um it was
awesome i started off on in february
i launched an event called sports hack
day
so this was a hackathon but for people
who wanted to build sports related
applications and technologies and i'm a
huge sports fan i don't know how many of
you are sports fans but uh
it was just really great to connect with
other people in the area that love
sports as much as i did and we held this
event during super bowl weekend um and
uh it was awesome so two days of hacking
and then we watched the super bowl
ordered a bunch of pizza had beer it was
a great time
in april i launched a community resource
called seattlehacks.com
and this is essentially an online
calendar of events
for developers and it was powered by
github pages and jekyll so anybody who
wanted to contribute could just fork the
repo submit a pull request and boom they
could contribute to this online resource
for developers in seattle um of course
there was going to be another
cascadia.js right
except this time it was going to be in
vancouver british columbia which was a
logistical challenge for me because uh i
live in seattle and i live in america um
so i had to think about like how i was
going to organize a conference in
another country but hey why stop uh at a
two-day conference when you could just
put on a whole week's worth of events um
so that's what i did um i worked with a
bunch of organizers in vancouver and we
organized vancouver devweek um a lot
like js fest right just a curated series
of great events for developers
and to kind of cap off a very busy 2013
um me and my friend ryan opened a
co-working space for developers in
seattle
we wanted to take everything that you
all that people love about meetups and
love about conferences we wanted to
create a space where people could have
where developers could have that
experience every single day so this was
a really busy year um and i was very
proud of everything that i had worked on
and i was honestly feeling really great
and i couldn't wait for 2014. i thought
2013 kicked ass i can't wait to see what
2014 is going to look like
and i will i will show you i will show
you what the first four months of 2014
looked like
yeah
yeah grumpy cat right
is very meh um and i'm this caught me
completely off guard right um i thought
i had figured everything out
um and i could not understand why i was
having such a rough first few months um
the first sign that something was wrong
um was that there was no follow-up to
sports hack day people were emailing me
they're like hey carter it's february is
coming up when's sports hack day and the
answer was it wasn't going to happen um
it wasn't going to happen because i was
too busy
and i couldn't even imagine like who
else could run it so i just sort of
decided that there wouldn't be another
sports hack day
and that was the first sign that
something was kind of wrong
but it wasn't just sports hack day
it just seemed like i was dropping the
ball a lot
i was dropping the ball with the
co-working space i was dropping the ball
at work um and this is just very it was
very unlike me um but at the time in the
middle of it i really didn't have a lot
of insight into like why this was
happening it just felt like man like
things are really tough and challenging
right now and i don't know why
and things came to a head uh in april so
i started working um with a remarkable
person named tracy heinz so people who
live in portland know who tracy is
she's one of the she she doesn't live
there anymore but she used to be one of
the most active organizers in portland
and i started working with her on the
next cascadia js and things started out
great um until they weren't and by the
time april rolled around
me and tracy were not working well
together we weren't communicating well
and she was incredibly frustrated with
me and i was just frustrated in general
i couldn't understand why things that
had gone so easy in 2013 were going so
hard so poorly in 2014.
so right around this time i'm flying
home from a conference
and i'm in a funk and i just want to
read a book and this is one of my
favorite authors i highly recommend
chuck klosterman he's amazing he's funny
he writes about pop culture and music
and sports
he's a former columnist for spin
magazine he does write in for the new
york times magazine he's great and i
just wanted to get my mind off of all
the stuff so i wanted to read one of his
books
and i'm on i'm on amazon.com and i find
this book that he wrote called killing
yourself to live the title is very
misleading it's basically about chuck
going on this road trip across the u.s
and it looked awesome so i started
reading the reviews and there's this one
review that where there was an excerpt
from the book and it really really
caught my eye and i want to read you the
excerpt
so
art and love are the same thing
they're the process of seeing yourself
in things that are not you
and i'm not kidding like at that moment
on that plane reading that quote this is
what happened to me
and honestly the people who were sitting
next to me on the plane probably thought
i was having a seizure or something um
and i know many of you in the audience
are like i don't get it like that's
let's so let's go back and revisit this
right
let's just look at art
let's say that art is the process of
seeing yourself in things that are not
you that's very reasonable to me right
if i'm an artist you know if i'm carving
a sculpture or writing a book or
creating a painting maybe
part of what is driving me as an artist
is to see myself manifested in these
inanimate objects that are not me you
know maybe that's a part of the creative
process
um
and that really resonated with me um and
it resonated with me specifically in
reference to all these things that i had
worked on
and i started to think back to the first
cascadia ajs and i really started to
examine what were the things that i
cared about
what were the things that i spent time
doing
what captured all of my energy and my
focus and it was stuff like this
so for those of you who love coffee
that's that's pour over coffee that's
one of the finest ways that you can
enjoy really really good coffee and i
spent weeks scouring seattle looking for
the best pour over coffee for
cascadia.js and it didn't stop there
right and you know i was meticulous
about you know what vendor to use for
the hoodies and like you know what food
trucks to get for the lunch
and you know and this was true of all
these things that i had worked on
and look you might be thinking like hey
like so what you know since when is it
news that people work on things that
they're passionate about or that reflect
their values like you're exactly right
this is not news but was what was news
to me was that i was completely focused
on all of those things and all of those
details
and i had completely
just forgotten about all the people that
i worked with to make these things
happen there's not a single thing that i
worked on that would have happened
without all of the people on this
monitor plus many more people that i
couldn't list
and when i really examined how
thoughtful i was about these people how
much time did i spend getting to know
them did i even understand why they were
helping me did i understand what they
were passionate about
the answer in many cases was no
and
i felt very ashamed when i realized this
because i think unwittingly i had
treated many of these people as a means
to an end
and that's just a terrible thing to do
and it's very unlike me
and so i absorbed this and you know i
just decided that like wow that'll never
ever happen again
um and uh and i i put it into practice
so in august we were you know the next
cascadia gs was gonna happen and i
really focused um on the people running
the conference right
tracy and ben and blaine and all these
wonderful people that were putting on
this conference i just focused on like
what i could do what could i do to help
them put on the best conference that
they could put on
and i think because of that i had the
best experience that i had ever had at a
cascadia js
it was remarkably rewarding to just see
what tracy and her team could do
and to sort of participate um solely
for the purpose of removing obstacles
from their path like that was really
really rewarding for me but beyond being
rewarding for me it was also just the
best cascadia.js ever by all objective
measures
and i think that that's the case because
i took a step back and i let someone
else execute their vision and they took
the conference to a place that i didn't
know it could go
um and it was really rewarding to to see
that happen
um so following the conference
i uh i just i really i really was you
know i really wanted to sit down and
think about everything that had happened
and i also reached out to a bunch of
other people who organized conferences
and hackathons and just other events in
the developer community you know i
talked to people like chris williams and
alex sexton and i'm very grateful
for them taking the time to talk to me
because i wanted to understand like look
is this just uh you know is this just a
me thing um or you know are other people
running into sort of similar issues who
are sort of who are involved in the
community and it turned out that there
were a lot of common issues um that were
uh that were kind of pervasive
throughout the developer community
so um
so whether you know you're you're
thinking about getting involved in the
community and i certainly hope that you
do because i think it's one of the most
rewarding experiences you can have
or you're just neck deep in it right now
i'd like to share a few things i learned
about being a little bit healthier and a
little bit happier doing this kind of
stuff
number one you need to watch for signs
that you're doing too much
and i've got a couple suggestions on
this
one
your work or your family start to suffer
right so every day you've got so many
hours
and you've got time with your family
time doing your job and then maybe
you've got some time left over to work
on your community obligations
when that community stuff starts to
creep out it is necessarily going to
impact like either your family or your
work or both so just really kind of keep
your keep your eye on like how things
are going at home or at work
you can't remember the last time you
said no
i'm
i'm guilty of this to this day i'm
terrible at saying no but i'm trying to
get better um when people reach out to
me and there's they they want some help
my instinct is to say yes i will help
you
because it makes me feel really good um
but you have to learn how to say no
and saying no isn't shutting somebody
down um the odds are that when someone
asks you for help you're not the best
you're not the person that could
actually help them the most um the odds
are that there's someone else out there
who can help them much more than you can
and if you're really involved in the
community and you know presumably you
have an idea of who that might be so
when these requests come in don't think
of no as shutting people down just try
to think of who could help them more
and lastly this is just a giant red flag
if you work on something that you care
about and you can't readily identify who
could take it over if you had to step
away then you're doing too much
and you're putting what you care at
what you care about at risk so you know
if you if you can't think of who should
take over that's a huge red flag it
means that you're not you're not really
sharing enough with the people that
you're working with um number two um how
to identify and find awesome people um i
wish that i could tell you that i have a
foolproof blueprint for doing this um i
don't but i have a couple suggestions
that i think are that have been really
helpful for me
one
really actively pay attention to the
amazing things that are going on all
around you and this sounds obvious but
for me it wasn't because i was heads
down
working on my stuff and i had blinders
on and i was very myopic
and you need to take the blinders off
and look around because people are doing
awesome things
i basically met tracy for the first
meaningful time when i went down to
portland because she was running
nodebots day in portland and i met her
and i saw firsthand what an amazing
organizer she was and that never would
have happened had it not taken the time
to just take the organizer hat off and
just go enjoy something in the community
also don't be afraid to ask for help
a lot of people think that this is a
sign of failure
and it really isn't um if you asking for
help is nothing more than raising your
hand and saying hey i'm really
passionate about something and i'd love
to work with somebody on this that's all
that is
two things to keep in mind though
you must be explicit about what you want
help with
to say that you know you just need help
with your meet up is not helpful to say
that you need help to say that you want
to record the talks at your meetup and
post them online is incredibly helpful
um and you need to be public about this
right
don't just talk to a few people you know
put it out there in as public a manner
because the truth is like you might not
know
a videographer um there might not be a
videographer that's directly connected
to you or someone that you know but if
you just put it out there publicly
you'll discover people that you didn't
know
and they'll want to help you
and then lastly
and i'm really still working on this um
take the time to get to know people um
to get to know these people like as
people like understand what they care
about what they're passionate about
this is i know that if i had done a
better job of this i never would have
accidentally treated people as a means
to an end
but i didn't i was really busy
and i didn't prioritize getting to know
the people that i was working with and i
think that's a huge mistake
um and then really this is uh the third
thing and this is sort of the real crux
of my talk and this is just a frame of
mind right stop thinking
like i'm working on a project
and start thinking like you're working
with people
um i'm starting to do this for the next
cascadia.js
i'm trying to be much less focused on
where it's going to be who's going to
talk all of those details and i'm trying
to be much more focused on who am i
going to work with on this remarkable
event and then the details will come
later but in order to do this i think
you need to do a few things
one you need to learn how to let go
guess what no one here has a kid under
six
okay if you have children under the age
of six you know who that is and you know
why this is funny or annoying um but no
you really do have to learn how to let
go
it
if you if you can't figure out how to
let go of these precious little things
that you've created you'll never succeed
in really sharing them with people
number two you need to get incredibly
serious about documentation and
communication and i don't care what
tools you use
tracy
used github and irc almost exclusively
for cascadia.js
the tools don't matter
but you have to get everything out of
your head and into a place where you can
work asynchronously with people
this is just incredibly important in
terms of sharing
and then the last thing and this is
really funny um
so i work for a platform company um and
we like to say at twilio that twilio is
incredibly uninteresting in a vacuum
like no one cares
what's cool
is what developers build on top of the
platform
and i think other people who work at
platform companies will you know will
sort of agree with that and it's weird i
had to relearn this in the context of
community like i had to relearn that
like it wasn't about what i did
by myself
like it was what it was what i could
help other people do like i had to
really redefine what success looked like
for me
um and i'm glad i did
because honestly uh you know my
involvement in the developer community
has been some of the most has provided
me with some of the most rewarding
experiences that i've ever had in my
life
and i'm very grateful that i ended up in
this place
so if you're thinking about getting
involved and i really hope you are
or if you're already very very involved
just just remember these three things
one don't try to do everything yourself
to
find people who share your passion
and three focus on what you can help
them accomplish
and lastly
for anyone here who might consider doing
this for a living
please come find me in the hallway track
i'd love to talk about evangelism love
to talk about twilio
and that is it for me thank you very
much